[Music]
arrowing I just can't stop it um killing
I thought I thought I just kill once to
try it but it's so Moorish I just had to
keep doing it
I'm sorry I'll go to jail and I'll leave
me Bible I'll never kill again
oh dear oh um I don't know sunshine I
mean that a newborn kitten the smile on
an old lady's face but mainly arrowing
good jacking up I just I love the needle
guy did I love her for he does your
brain I like the way if you lose all
bodily function
Oh God I was sensible for half an hour
what do you expect what
I like staying in I like I love you know
having a nice safe home sit there my
girlfriend and my cat watching telly
loving loving Dexter loving damages I
love doing the podcast with karl
Pilkington friendship friends friends
and loved ones that is I mean obviously
it is but I sort of I do I do count my
blessings every day oh thanks just a
little five-pound bag um hi
yeah okay you know um a walk in the
woods that may be helping an elderly man
across the round I like starting race
riots just to see what happens
[Music]